I'm here with Annie from the glamour
team and we're talking about our
favorite obsession which is youthful
glowing skin so we're using Rimmel wake
me up foundation loaded with vitamin C
which really boost your skin's vitality
and brightness I'm gonna use a very soft
kind of stippling brush just is the tip
of the brush to take the foundation and
you can start in the center of the face
small circular motions will really help
to blend this foundation in perfectly it
also has an SPF of 15 which is great you
know your skin can be very protected so
you get a very even looking perfect skin
that looks full of vitality and
brightness so we're gonna move on to
your under-eye area and I'm using the
wake me up concealer which is perfect as
a highlighter the applicators really
handy on this it's a little doe foot so
you can start by just dotting underneath
the eyes and even taking it onto your
cheekbones you're going to use this as a
bit of a highlighter today and just
gently blend the concealer Annie I know
that you're a huge fan of a sculpted
looking cheek and I'm using Rimmel's
first ever sculpting palette it has a
really beautiful tone from highlight to
contour to blush now my top tip here is
to start gently highlight the top of
your cheekbones which works really well
with that foundation and I'm also a huge
fan of a nose highlight and a pop a
little bit on your chin so to finish
your jewelry look I'm using the brows
this way highlighting pencil perfect for
underneath the arches and to finish off
and touch on the Cupid's bow so this is
one we Kate Moss range I'm just going to
take it straight from the bullet into a
lip and just to soften the look at the
end take your fingertip and just press
it in perfect
you